In the penultimate episode of Star Trek: Picard's
first season, La Sirena finally reaches its
destination, Soji learns the truth of her
origins, and Picard sees an unexpected familiar
face.
Here are all the Easter eggs and references
you might have missed in "Et in Arcadia Ego
Part I."
When La Sirena finally arrives at Soji's homeworld,
Soji reveals that the planet's synthetic inhabitants
call it "Coppelius."
This is almost assuredly a reference to the
19th century ballet Coppélia, in which a
young man falls in love with a life-size doll.
In the ballet, the doll's inventor, Dr. Coppelius,
plans to sacrifice the young man in order
to bring his creation to life.
However, the young man's fiance manages to
save him by dressing up as the doll, and using
Coppelius' other creations as a distraction
so that the young couple can escape.
The first part of the plot sounds eerily similar
to what Picard and his crew encounter on the
planet Coppelius, where Dr. Alton Inigo Soong
is willing to sacrifice the lives of all "organics"
in order to ensure the continued existence
of his sentient synthetic creations.
Shortly after La Sirena first arrives at Coppelius,
Narek's ship also emerges from the transwarp
conduit and immediately begins to attack.
After trading shots back and forth, Narek's
ship suddenly seems to be experiencing some
sort of technical malfunction, with its cloaking
device glitching out and Narek's life signs
quickly fading.
Picard orders Narek beamed aboard La Sirena,
but it turns out that it was all just a distraction.
The ship they were seeing was actually a projection
of Narek's cloaking device.
Really, his ship was behind La Sirena, and
he exploited their attempt at mercy to attack
them again.
While the mechanics are different, Narek's
strategy is extremely reminiscent of the "Picard
Maneuver," a battle tactic Picard invented
while commanding the Stargazer that created
the illusion of a second ship.
"And blowing into maximum warp speed, you
appeared, for an instant, to be in two places
at once."
"And our attacker fired on the wrong one."
Although Narek used his cloaking device to
create that illusion, both tactics involved
confusing the opposing ship's sensors and
tricking them into firing on the illusion
instead of the real ship.
After La Sirena crash lands on the surface
of Coppelius, the ship seems largely undamaged,
except that none of the ship's automated systems
are up and running.
This presents a problem for Agnes Jurati,
who is tasked with figuring out what's wrong
with Picard after the Admiral starts speaking
nonsensically on the bridge.
Although the medical scanners aren't working,
Agnes lucks out when she finds an old med
kit.
"I didn't know how I was going to run a scan
on you, and then I found this.
An old-school medical tricorder."
Of course, medical tricorders are familiar
to anyone who has watched previous iterations
of Star Trek, but the most significant person
from Picard's past to use a medical tricorder
was Dr. Beverly Crusher, the Chief Medical
Officer on board the Enterprise.
Dr. Crusher was also Picard's closest friend
and, in one version of the future, his wife,
although they later got divorced.
When the La Sirena crew ventures out onto
the surface of Coppelius, Raffi attributes
her nerves to the possibility of encountering
"angry reptiloids" or "homicidal fungi."
Neither of these is outside the realm of possibilities
on Star Trek.
In the original series, the most notable encounter
with an angry reptiloid occurred in the episode
"Arena," in which Captain Kirk is told he
must fight to the death with the captain of
a Gorn ship.
As for homicidal fungi, while no Star Trek
crew has yet had a run-in with murderous mushrooms,
in the original series episode "The Conscience
of the King," the crew of the Enterprise encounters
the former governor of a colony responsible
for massacring 4,000 of his colonists after
an aggressive strain of exotic fungi wiped
out most of their food stores.
The governor's justification for his homicidal
actions was that he was trying to ensure that
at least some of his people would live, even
if it meant sacrificing many of them.
This is not too far off from the logic presented
by Sutra in "Et in Arcadia Ego, Part I," in
which she argues that wiping out all organic
life in the universe is a worthwhile tradeoff
if it ensures that the synthetic race will
live on.
After arriving on Coppelius, the long-range
sensors on the crashed Borg cube confirm that
a fleet of Romulan warbirds is indeed on its
way to the planet, and will arrive uncomfortably
soon.
Raffi tells Rios that in total, there are
218 warbirds approaching, although Raffi jokes
that they really only have to worry about
the first 109.
While it's always hard to say for sure whether
numbers like these are supposed to be a reference
to anything at all, 218 could be a nod to
the fifth season Next Generation episode "Cause
and Effect," which was given production code
218.
In the episode, the Enterprise gets caught
in a time loop, and only manages to escape
once Data figures out a way to send a message
to himself through time, giving him the information
he needs to break the loop.
In "Et in Arcadia Ego, Part I," Sutra realizes
that the Admonition is a message being sent
from an ancient race of synthetics to the
synthetic lifeforms of the future.
Keeping with the idea of production codes,
the Next Generation episode "Justice" was
given the code 109, and sees Picard facing
off against a powerful and highly advanced
being who watches over a race of less advanced
people.
In "Justice," Picard opposes the death sentence
given to an innocent member of his crew, arguing
that there is nothing just about such an extreme
unilateral punishment that doesn't take individual
circumstances into account - a similar argument
to the one we see him attempt to make at the
end of "Et in Arcadia Ego, Part I."
When Picard and the crew of La Sirena arrive
in Coppelius Station, we get a brief glimpse
of two synthetics playing a game that looks
very similar to the 3D chess that has been
seen on several other versions of Star Trek.
One episode of The Next Generation in which
3D chess played a prominent role was in a
third season episode in which Will Riker uses
his captors' game to maneuver his way out
of his cell after he and Deanna Troi are taken
hostage.
Picard will likely have to employ similar
levels of cunning and strategic thinking in
order to escape the circumstances he finds
himself in at the end of "Et in Arcadia Ego,
Part I."
When the golden-skinned synthetic Sutra is
introduced, Dr. Soong mentions that she is
extremely interested in Vulcan culture, saying
that she has read Surak and "plays the ka'athyra
beautifully," and has even taught herself
how to perform a Vulcan mind meld.
Surak was the revered Vulcan philosopher who
helped shape Vulcan culture with his teachings
on peace and logic.
Meanwhile, the ka'athyra was a form of Vulcan
lute.
"It is a five stringed instrument, tuned to
a diatonic scale.
It can be very soothing."
Several characters have played the ka'athyra
on past iterations of Star Trek, including
Spock and Uhura on the original series, and
Tuvok on Voyager.
One of the cuddliest recurring characters
on The Next Generation was Data's ginger housecat,
Spot, who appeared in numerous episodes.
Caring for Spot and bonding with the cat was
a pivotal part of Data's ongoing quest to
become more human.
"And you must talk to him.
Tell him he is a pretty cat.
And a good cat."
In "Et in Arcadia Ego, Part I," Agnes is seen
cuddling a remarkably familiar ginger housecat,
whom she confirms is even named, "Spot II."
But don't get too excited about Spot's family
tree continuing on through 2399; this version
of Spot is actually a synthetic, created by
Soong and seemingly modeled after the original
Spot.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Trek
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.